[Musique]
pour cela les enfants
boussois bouge toi patrick boudet sent
tout de suite voir nicolas et
pimprenelle bon le cheval que tu es
pressé nounours je le veux pas laisser à
ses deux petits garnements le temps de
me préparer une blague et le gel ce coup
ci il ne manqueront pas patron vous
allez voir ce que vous allez voir
pop en europe en particulier je suis
direct ndar bonsoir petit pas preneur et
mopti
elle me peu utiles dont ne s'est pas
tarie non nicolas da fronton
ça c'est une blague minos indoor
je vais voir quand bear alors il dort
frémaux
[Applaudissements]
faisons preuve oui patronne
enfin la part dieu
l'agent de police autre but cela fait
onze mois que désiré ou le sillage haut
ce que je désire monsieur voilà vous
avez une contravention une contravention
oui monsieur lellouche pourquoi que j'ai
contrat bravo vous avez eu une
contravention
qu'est-ce que vous avez garé votre nuage
dans un stationnement interdit et ça va
vous coûter cher menti car un
stationnement interdits en l'air c'est
très très cher mais les avions les
avions qui volent une contravention nous
et vous devez me payer 10 microns je
n'ai pas d'autre chose c'est du propre
bravo monsieur à voir votre permis de
conduire
c'est à dire train
jeunot dernier allo nicolas
o le coq et moi qui croyais que c'était
un vrai agent de police au 7e rang petit
garnement attendu que je vous attrape on
est donné tu peux plus rien faire on est
sage au long des enfants adorent mais
vous faites pas dénuée de risques en
rien j'éteins la lumière de l'école a
lancé denis dessus la jambe
bonne nuit par brawn l atome
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
paquet patrons ont eu une contravention
donne le nours merci je vais la faire
sauter par dessus notre nuage
et hop voilà
plus de contraventions vous savez y
faire vous pas trop allons en route
mon fidèle nounours à vos genre draw mon
fils est le patron
bonne nuit les enfants fêtes de bourg
ah ah
[Musique]